sooo Gareth were here at kapow comic
convention you've been on a panel today
haven't you and it was a director's
panel tell me a bit about it an
interesting that came up towards the end
was about inspiration and where'd you
get it and do you ever find that you've
copied something or what film most did
you imitate and then we all started
getting into like the fact that it's
sort of subconscious and you sort of
realize it sometimes too late oh yeah
that's where that shot came from it's
from that movie and then you have to
decide do I now get rid of it because
it's too similar to that movie that I
love or do I just leave it in and just
consider it like subconscious
inspiration and and its really really
it's really nice to know that everybody
has that because you sort of do it
yourself and think you feel like guilty
there that all these films it's
inevitable really but all these films
that inspires you when you want growing
up I going to just find that language is
going to find its way into your
filmmaking because it's like it's like a
parent speak English and then somehow
trying not to speak English when you
open your mouth of course you can do and
so so yes there are certain films I
think going to find it hard to like make
movies without without being infected a
little bit by them it's interesting
isn't it I mean did you find for example
with monsters that maybe there were
scenes like you said that you thought oh
yes that's been influenced by such and
such thing but maybe when critics or the
audiences were watching it afterwards
there were things that you hadn't picked
up on or that you hadn't no [ __ ] so are
actually yeah yeah there was loads um
like I did set out I didn't set out to
make a political film at all it's not a
political film but I set out to have a
layer of politics just tucked under the
love story and the layer of politics I
was trying to do but I thought was
interesting was that this idea this
metaphor for if if if there are monsters
and they kill people like at what price
is it worth defeating the monsters if
you kill more people trying to get rid
of them than they would ever kill is it
still worth doing which is very
obviously a parallel to like the war on
terror like we're killing so many
innocent people trying to stop terrorism
the Middle East and terrorists have ever
killed so it was a little bit like a
little question it wasn't a comment just
like a question like let's but you try
and say it out loud in other types of
films and he look like you're preaching
but if you were put in a sci-fi movie
you kind of get away with it well people
don't even notice and then we showed the
movie in Texas for the first time itself
by Southwest and all the questions were
like what your films obviously about
immigration and you know the mex Mexican
immigration into America and the wall
and the journey and and you were like oh
yeah of course they can yeah like it was
not of course it was going to come along
but it was it's kind of disappointed
that that's what everyone was reading
into it because it wasn't I wanted it to
be about this thing about war and is it
right you know to do like there's a
scene in the film where is his candles
and we put it in Spanish to try and keep
it really subtle but they're like one of
the things we put up was who other
monsters someone a graffiti on a wall
and and I felt like that represented the
movie that question and that's why it's
called monsters and it just got lost
lady was too and it was two layered too
deep and it just and yeah so what I go
went into it trying to create it's not
what someone else watching it will
perceive or C and so but I think that's
the beauty of anything like like you
know it's like your favorite music when
you don't have the lyrics and you think
you know what they're saying but they
sing it quite weird and so you and
there's so many songs where I think they
saying these certain sentences and it
means so much to me because they're
talking metaphorically so perfectly
about my life and then suddenly read the
album and you and it's Eve it it's not
even the words you think it is and it's
quite heartbreaking because you feel
like and I heard that Thom Yorke stopped
printing his legs on Radiohead albums
because he felt I think correctly that
it really doesn't matter what the words
are it's what you hear you know
and it's a cop-out that's a massive
cop-out for people who are creative but
I do I grew a lot I feel like you make a
film you're trying to do certain things
you're trying to create a film I think
that if you hadn't made it you would
like and but then once you've done it
you let go and whatever it is it is to
other people and they'll start telling
you what they think like it's crap yeah
I don't I think that's out of your
control then then you don't own it
anymore and it's gone
you